to my video. So, as you can see here,
this is my KGO visualizer website. And
uh for those who don't already know,
Katago is a it's an AI go engine similar
to Alpha Go, which is very popular like
10 years ago. Um it's like similarly,
Kado is like super strong and no human
can really possibly beat it, I'll say.
And the purpose of this website is
really simple to like to basically help
people understand how tal works as well
as uh to help them analyze their game
and to improve their go technique. So,
uh let me just show you how this works.
So, here I'm going to like refresh my
website. It's going to show you a demo.
Uh so, first you can see it's a loading
screen and once it once it finish
loading it's going to show you a game
board like a real go game board. And
there's like the control buttons and
move forward or go backward. Yeah. Um so
let's say this is the first move. The
black places at 16 Q16 and all of these
red uh like moves. Um there are the
recommended recommended moves uh by
Kate. So
um the more r the a move is the like the
more recommendated level recommendation
level cl like or like the more t
recommends this move. Um
so in this case d4 is obviously most
recommended move although you might say
maybe like this move has a win rate of I
don't know 56.9. Why didn't Tado choose
it? Well, to be honest, I can't really
answer this question, but uh based on
Tado's order, this move is the best
move. And actually, I agree because I'm
also go player. Uh and if you scroll
scroll down, you can see there's a V
rate graph. Um so, as we move forward,
you can see this graph is also getting
updated. It's going to show you the uh
live win rate for each move. and select
how you change. Um, also you can hover
your you can actually hover your mouse
over the graph and it's going to show
you a uh ready to line and you can like
hover on it and to basically
get to the move you want. It's like
super quickly.
Okay. So um in terms of the technical
part um this website as you can see here
is made of it's actually separated into
a into back end and front end. So for
front end uh is mainly made with react
and just basically pure HTML CSS.
Um this game board is pure HTML kama uh
with uh with a few like packages but
okay and this uh vinary graph this is
made by uh charjs or in specific for
react it's char I think it's react
chargs too and uh overall I'll say front
end is kind of simple and
uh for back end well back end this uh I
I I use the general or actually the the
general rest framework for back end. So
the general rest framework it basically
allows me to open a host open a like
like basically a window to uh process
the request sent from my front end which
is my react or just like website you can
see here. Um so what does it do is that
it's going to take requests from my
front end which is my react also I use
apps for uh sending requests in my front
end. So once you receive a request, it's
going to process the request and send a
uh request like another request to my
AWS which stands for Amazon web service
EC2 server and the EC2 server because
it's uh specifically GPU is a lot
stronger than my local machine. So it's
going to process the data and like a lot
quicker than my local to my uh local
machine and send the data back to my uh
the general rest framework and and then
I'm going to forward this uh response to
to my uh front end code my react like
the website you see here. Um yeah and
that's like a complete request.
Um, yeah. Anyways, that's basically how
my website work.